peace
good afternoon everyone
colleagues
just going to start by asking mrs
sternberg to go through a few items with
your screen
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
if the alarm sounds please make your way
to the primary exit
you should only use the secondary door
if the primary door is
[Music]
[Music]
close and do not work
does not place
chair requests that you do not stand
for today so that you can get as close
to the microphone as possible
turn will operate the lights and switch
them all along
[Music]
hear that
thank you
[Music]
before we start the official agenda
just wanted to say a few words
because it is with sadness that we all
learned the passing of councillor and
holmes
she represented pilsley and morton ward
since 1991
and served as chair of the council from
2010 to 2011
and again from 2015 to 2016
during her time in office
and supported help for heroes
and north darvish's stroke support group
and was also a former member of pilsley
parish council
and for a time the vice chair
she was an unassuming person
who had a reputation in her community
for caring for others
on behalf of the council
i convey our sincere sympathies
to her family and friends
and they asked colleagues to join me in
silence
as we remember councillor holmes
thank you
i am going to invite the leader of the
labour group to say a few words
thank you chair
that's me
[Music]
and like you've said and i've been a
district councillor for a whole world
and i maintain that
people become councillors for a variety
of reasons but
i reckon the majority of us on both
sides on all sides
get involved because they want to help
their local communities
and i think anne was a perfect example
of that
she never had any aspirations to be an
mp or even to be leader of our group
i don't think so anyway
it's no coincidence that the people of
philly and morton
continue to vote for ant
uh the people in that area know if
someone is genuine or not
uh and their main priority is
representing the
the people of pilsly and more
more cruelly to be honest
but to conclude i think we can all agree
anne was a selfless woman for their art
in the right place
who did all she could to make pilsley
and more in a better place for the
people who lived and worked there on
behalf of the labour group i'd like to
pass on our condolences to our family
and recognize the work and did as a
counsellor both at the district and the
parish so thank you
for allowing me to speak
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
um i'd just like to echo um
[Music]
obviously i've known him for many years
and i've always
admired a desire
to make things better for local people
particularly in the building area where
she lived all her life
she was a real community
leader and a really community-minded
person
she worked tirelessly
and she will beat
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
spoken i didn't know ann uh well
but i do remember in my first year as a
counselor she was chair of the council
very welcoming person very friendly and
should be deeply missed i'm sure
by all across the chamber and our on
behalf of the conservatives
[Music]
agenda then please so apologists for
absence have been received from
councillors
gomez rini
parking and lilly
are there any other apologies
[Music]
decorations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interest and any items on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
are there any decorations council gail
thank you i think i'm is trying to
intend uh being a county councillor that
i should declare the interest
there's nothing
that would be there to be a conflict
so
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
um i will remain if that is
okay um
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
meeting held on the third of march 2022
have been circulated
sorry seventh of march
[Music]
it says the council councillor parking
um
gave a report
on the level of council tax
and
it's not here it weren't there at that
meeting either
so that obviously
[Music]
so with the meetings acceptance of that
council parking did not provide a report
it was council dale so that will be
amended in the minutes if you're all
happy with that
so it's been moving seconded all in
favor with the amendment
and run against
and the abstentions
that's carrying thank you
item four chairs announcement
on the 14th of april the consort and i
represented the council at the funeral
of mrs freda walker
former consort of bolzova district
council
the service was well attended by a
community who wanted to show their
respect for all frieda along with her
husband ken
had achieved on their behalf
it was pointing for many reasons
it was of course a funeral that was too
soon
frieda's life was taken away in tragic
circumstances and shocked us all
may she rest in peace
in addition we have attended the civic
services for amber valley borough
council and bolsonaro district
our council's civic service for the
queen's jubilee visit st john's church
walton on the 22nd of may
it'll be great to see you there
gina and i visited camp inspire
organized by chesterfield community
trust for the whole of the easter
holidays for children on three school
meals from chesterfield and northeast
derbyshire
it was wonderful to see participants
engaging in worthwhile activities that
helped to build self-esteem
it truly was
inspirational
events such as camp inspire are
important aspects of the civic role
as is fundraising for our chosen charity
i wish to thank councillor ross shipman
for offering to have a sponsored haircut
to realize funds for the hospice i
believe it's 500 pounds
[Music]
so as you can see he survived the ordeal
and
didn't allow me anywhere near his hair
apparently i can't keep a steady hand
so thank you council shipment for your
support
tickets are now on sale for my big band
bonanza on the 14th of may
featuring guest speaker
general david leakey who was former
black rod in parliament
also will be the kalamazoo
dance band for that glenn miller sound
so let's hope that you can get
in the mood
it's the best i can do i couldn't think
of any other jokes
to come along for my last fundraising
event
wipe those tears away
thank you so item five leaders
announcements
thank you uh chair we have a busy agenda
so there are just three main items i
wanted to update trains on the first was
the homestead ukraine scheme um since
the scheme was first announced officers
have been
extremely busy working to meet the
requirements on local authorities we're
working very closely with other district
borough councils as well as the county
council
as well as other partner organizations
including
in the community and voluntary sector
and our core role within the guidance is
to provide the home safety checks
and i'm really pleased to say that our
environmental health team
have been leading the way across the
county in terms of establishing a
standardized digital accommodations
inspection process
which should be available for all
authorities to use throughout the county
and it also collects data support to
support the council council in carrying
out the dbs check as well
in addition officers have worked hard to
pull together a comprehensive welcome
pack for ukrainian arrivals uh to ensure
that they quickly feel at home in the
district and also to understand how to
access all the relevant services that
they might need for example libraries uh
leisure centers uh house contact the
counsellor
has come to get in touch with the parish
council all of those sorts of things
that you know
people arriving in the area not knowing
the area very well might need to uh to
think about accessing
we've also provided all ukrainian
arrivals with a free leisure pass
for use in any of our four facilities uh
both for the purposes of promoting
health and well-being but also so that
they can keep in touch with us by
visiting our services and hopefully meet
people locally as well
finally i was really pleased to be able
to pay a visit to uh who we believe was
the first family to arrive in north east
derbyshire to welcome them and also to
say a huge thank you on behalf of the
district to the sponsored couple and it
goes without saying that this huge thank
you extends to all those who've decided
to do something amazing by pledging to
senate sponsor guests from ukraine
moving on we've recently received the
details of our uk shared prosperity fund
grant from the government which totals
2.57
at million pounds for northeast
governorship the fund is intended to
spread opportunity and prosperity to all
of our communities
we're informed that the fund allows a
high degree of flexibility
so that local decision making can help
help target it towards local priorities
and needs
the cabinet is going to meet with senior
officers in the coming weeks to discuss
how we can utilize this important
funding
and we will obviously share details with
colleagues
in due course as as they arrive as they
arise
and then finally in terms of climate
change i really wanted to highlight a
recent success
in being named by friends of the earth
as one of 40 councils in the country
leading the way on tap on climate change
in particular they highlighted the
council and wrigle's work on
retrofitting ewi to hundreds of homes
across the district helping to reduce
carbon emissions and energy bills for
our tenants and friends of the earth had
this to say north east alberta district
council has navigated complex funding
opportunities to make sure it
prioritizes energy efficiency upgrades
for the council house residents in most
need this is important work that joins
up the climate emergency with addressing
fuel poverty we'll obviously be hearing
more about this important work later on
in the agenda
thank you very much
thank you so item six is public
participation but i can advise you that
no questions have been submitted by the
public so remove flight in seven
the independent re-enumeration panel
members allowance scheme so i'm going to
hand over now to the assistant director
of governance and monitoring officer to
present the report
thank you
council has a duty to appoint an
independent independent remuneration
panel to review the members allowances
now the duty to do this on a regular
basis
that panel has now met
details the members of the panel are
empowered 1.2 of the report
they had a considerable amount of
information to compare relating to the
members announces that other districts
and boroughs in the council
and this is also listed in the report
having considered the information
supplied and that the announcement
recently the panel concluded that they
should recommend an increase in line
with the previously recommended
increases
the recommendations therefore propose an
increase for all the members allowances
with the exception of pc consumables
there is a member working party
currently looking at members ict and so
this will be looked at further due
course by that group
there is no recommendation to increase
the parties allowance there is also a
recommendation to indexing the
allowances with the increases in future
to staff pay awards for the next four
years
finally you are being asked to approve
the members allowances scheme for
2022-23
including the above changes
and if members could indicate if they
want me to repeat any of that
please let me know
so you've got the recommendations of
pages 22 and 23
or
23 24. if you ever move it
council there's a second council cupid
do we have any questions
council barca
[Music]
thank you chair
uh yeah
we we can't say this i don't consider it
given that the motion that we've
submitted we don't feel that at this
time it's appropriate we
would feel hypocritical really to vote
for this at this time so
and that's not to undermine the work we
do as councillors in the democratic
process obviously uh because i think we
should should be valued in that role for
at this time we don't think you should
go for it to be accepting this increase
thank you
chancellor shipman
hello um yeah i i agree with councillor
here i think it would have been good i
don't know if this is possible for us to
vote
on either removing one and two of the
recommendations
or
voting on them in chunks here because i
can support the rest
but i cannot support one and two is
which is to increase members allowances
and the increase in the sra
stuff um if you remember i brought a
motion here what were it a year two year
ago
where
uh councillor dale stood up and said
what's the point in adopting this
because we're not going to increase
members allowances elsewhere in this
current term
well here we are
now looking at increasing members
allowances
so either it was misleading
at that point or
something else but i i can't see how i
would provoke this especially after the
promises that have been made by the
leadership of this council
any comments or questions
just
failed to reply
are you highlighting that these are um
at the beginning of the paper refers to
increases that
were set before even our administration
uh came into power
that they weren't implemented in the
past two years there is a two-year
saving in the financial recommendations
financial implications rather for not
having implemented any increases for the
previous two years uh i have sympathy
with with the view of of both of the
groups and groups i think it's always a
difficult uh thing to do but the whole
point of having an independent
rememberation channel is that it's
independent of the council we shouldn't
set our own uh wages we can set our own
salaries and having it looked at
independently is the best way to do it
you know if we were to then turn around
and reject those or amend them to
something completely different that
wouldn't be independent anymore it'd be
politicians interfering with how they
are paid so i think from my perspective
although it's a difficult decision and i
don't think it's something that we
that we particularly enjoy doing at this
moment in time clearly there's a you
know custom living issues and all the
other things but to reject this
for me
what's the point of having the irp in
the first place
[Music]
but we are going to go to the vote i'm
going to split the recommendations
so we are going to take one and two
together
and then three and nine together
so we're voting on
the recommendations one and two on page
23.
so all those in favor
[Music]
show your hands
against
any abstentions
so one and two are carried
so we now go to recommendations three to
nine inclusive
all those in favor
those against
the abstentions
two abstentions three to nine are
carried
thank you
so now move to item eight the proposed
calendar of meetings for twenty twenty
two
twenty three
back to you mr sternberg
thank you chair
each year the council has to agree its
schedule of meetings for the fourth
coming year a draft is presented
following expensive consultation with
respect to the legal needs for the
timing and meetings
attached is a draft for your
consideration and approval
the recommendations are on page 34 and
include a delegation for me to amend the
calendar meetings following discussions
with the relevant chair
so you can see the recommendations we
have a proposal please answer dale thank
you a second
council cupid thank you are there any
comments or questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes thank you chairman
uh the um
principal meeting in may will be one
which is already in the diary on the
17th there's another one uh which is
later in the month i think towards the
end of may and that's been put in
essentially um just almost as a holding
measure if it was required if the
meeting is not required then with the
agreement of the chair the meeting will
be cancelled and then the next planning
committee will be the one in june thank
you
thanks for that
one thing i would raise is um i know
audit that i sit on the meeting started
for me and wants to become apparent i'm
going to die is that i have to pick my
kiddo
from child care before almost five from
nothing so i have to get from here to
nottingham pick my kid up on a wednesday
every week
and
turn around time to get from our meeting
all day today
you know sometimes after this end of
that meeting or
i have to pay the fine if i'm late
picking him up so it would be nice to
consider
like having an either a bit earlier or
you know after that point
so this is a perennial question that's
come up the last 16 years that i know of
and what we've always said is that
it's down to individual chairs of
scrutiny committees in consultation with
committee
to agree times and dates and i think the
problem is you'll never sue everyone
and so that's down to the individual
schools in the committee that you're on
and i know ultimately some people have
to change spiritually because of that
and
but
they're they're the provisional dates as
they stand until the beginning of the
new civic year subject to wherever the
chairs are
any other comments or questions
it's not to be moved and seconded can we
go to the vote then please all those in
favor
anyone against
any abstentions
thank you carrie
so
[Music]
the council's constitution was reviewed
annually through the standards committee
recommendations are then made for
changes and these are contained in the
table attached to support for you
in relation to the jcg changes this is
subject to further consideration so it
is a
the report outlines the matches that
standards committee have recommended and
there are all
these are also listed at page 59 at 2.2
and i'm sorry i haven't got the
recommendations
recommendations are on page 57
so
we need a proposal thank you council
armitage and the secondary thank you
councillor anthony
are there any comments or questions
please
mrs counselor
thank you chair and i just wanted to ask
about the changes on the petitions
scheme
[Music]
be acceptable by the council is uh to be
made by the head of the paid service
and what there isn't there is any kind
of criteria
or any description on what might be an
acceptable petition and what might not
it would be useful to have that in
advance so that people didn't waste
their time putting things in that were
going to be not acceptable and it would
be good guidance to forming petitions if
they knew what the criteria was for
acceptance or not thank
[Music]
this was meant to deal with a very
narrow situation where there's some form
of consultation going on to deal with
the subject matter petition
and the council have to look at whether
the consultation would be invalidated if
they dealt with a petition it's not
criteria for petitioning first place i
will look to clarify that to make it
clear
now you've raised it but it's not meant
to affect normal petitions outside that
situation
thank you chair um one thing i would
raise and it's related to my motion
later on
is that there's
a constitutional process failure in how
we handle
revoking plan adaptations because in
order for the planning committee to
debate revoking again it has to come
here first
and then go back to planning which you
know that time frame could be weeks
uh if it's not time for perfect day
and therefore that costs the council
money in if the longer that goes on
um and it would be good if let's say the
chair of the planning committee could
put something on
the planning committee or i don't know
just looking a number out in here like
four planning committee members could
make that request so something goes back
on the planning committee
so i think it's wrong but
all 53 of us are voting have to vote to
put something on what really is just a
process issue and there needs to be like
some room for the chair or members of
that committee to put something back on
their living discussion because as
you'll hear later the planetary has
always been helpless in handling that
particular issue
um and like i think we need to look at
how to change the constitution to give
members that ability to do that
[Music]
this is about um the petition team back
up it was under the last administration
that a change to the position scheme was
introduced which
barred any uh petitions coming to full
council that were on any matter that
that was or may ever be subject to
consultation and the local plan
um
and that had the effect of preventing a
4 000 signature position on the green
belt coming to have a debate in this
chamber so having this rule change that
allows
lee as an emerging director to to you
know go against that policy i think
there's a step in the right direction
this is that opening the positions being
backed up it's not about closing it down
in any way
[Music]
you would comment some questions
do you want to
reply
[Music]
[Music]
and it was approved by all members and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for item 10 the vision
derbyshire county deal and evolution
is anything you want to add
i think we dealt with decorations
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not proposing to go through it in
detail it's there on the page uh so just
a few hopefully quick remarks as we'll
say um clearly vision darvish has
progressed over the past year or so
albeit it's sort of fairly gradual
change
there is now a joint committee with an
established terms of reference and a
business unit uh has been established to
support the the project work uh four
authorities so far have taken the
decision to join us full uh constituent
members um at north establishing we have
yet to take any decision on this and if
we do intend to join them it will be a
matter for full council to determine um
at the moment uh with what's happening
with the counter deals which i've come
on to and the potential provision
derbyshire to need to be tweaked in
order to fit within any structure of a
counter deal then my view is that we
should wait for the time being and see
what the outcome is before taking any
decision on whether to subscribe to the
full
vision diversity model
that said we continue to be a full
active participant in the vision derby
project
as non-constituent members alongside
other uh councils who haven't joined as
well uh indeed we continue to take a
leading role within the climate change
work stream
with lee hickey as the lead officer
within the county and i know councillor
kenyon has been part of
all the meetings uh the product of which
we'll be discussing in the next as an
exciting on the agenda
it remains my firm believe that we
should continue to collaborate with
fellow councillors with invision
darbyship
as there are real benefits to be
achieved for both ourselves and for our
residents and businesses
but i hope you'll agree that it's right
to take a pragmatic approach around
whether or not to join as a full member
until things become clear with
devolution
the paper before you today is asking for
endorsement of this position uh but
continuing to have a seat at the table
and playing an active role working with
other councils under the umbrella
revision partnership and the paper also
covers what we know about counterfeits
and devolution at this stage again i
won't repeat what it says but instead
i'll make a few key points
we are still very clearly at a very
early stage in the negotiation process
and there will be a lot of information
discussion that's likely to arise over
the coming weeks and months the exact
nature of the final deal and what that
will look like is still very much to be
determined uh contrary to what some
people are saying this is not about
overcoming reform or utilization the
white paper is absolutely clear that
there is still a role for district and
borough councillors to play in all of
this uh albeit without the power of the
veto which is held back previously
evolution deals um it is likely that
there will be both opportunities and
possibly some challenges that arise out
of the final deal
and we need to play a participative role
in the discussions over the coming weeks
and months in order to truly understand
what is an offer to what role we can
play and how we can champion the
interests of residents and businesses
within northern establishment
i know some councils have taken an early
decision to isolate themselves from this
whole process and in my view bury their
heads in the sand hoping it will go away
i really can't stress enough that i
think that that is the wrong approach
for this council whether we like it or
not demolition in some form is going to
happen in derbyshire sooner or later and
our residents and communities are best
served by us being firmly at the table
willing and ready to discuss options
participating with fellow councils for
common good for the common good and
being ready to champion the interests of
our districts
that's the approach we're seeking the
endorsement of uh today the continuation
of
and clearly we'll bring further updates
in future meetings as a situation with
the counter deal
develops uh there are the meetings that
are being organized by the county to
keep all members invited informed and
please do uh attend those where you're
able to i'll keep sending the
invitations out as i receive them but on
that note chair i'm happy
[Music]
thank you chair
uh yeah thanks alex and i i've heard
what you've said
and i've read through the paper several
times and i've tried to line it with it
with this stuff i've been hearing
impressive on television
about this super authority and the
combined authority
uh
i'm i'm struggling to see
where we fit with this it does
listen to what you've said and you'll
say it's the start of a process whilst
others feel like a fake company that
we're already signing up we're down the
road of signing for that and my question
to all of it is it wasn't it for north
east derbyshire because my fear and it's
shared by our group
and it has been portrayed elsewhere that
this will lead to elect
electing an elected mayor and
subsequently would deal with government
and i know we're on start of that road
but this feels like very much
which will probably mean an end
down the line of district councils
i accept what you that you're not
admitting to that and it's been stressed
in the zoo meetings that i've been to
that that that's not the intention
but and it is a big vote i'm afraid i
don't trust what you're telling us i
really don't
to be blunt this is the problem when
we're going got a leader
of our authority is also a cabinet
member of another authority and other
members on the county council as was
argued a while ago there's a clear
conflict of interest here and
it's always our leader represented is it
this authority or the county council
again to be frank
we believe this is the first step to
electing a mayor for derbyshire darby
nottinghamshire knocking them and if if
we do that i reckon i know where the
majority they're leveling up only number
and it'll not be northeast harvesting
also when we get a report that comes
late and is part of agenda with 396
pages that makes me suspicious
that we've got some have died
whilst we support the concept division
derbyshire and authorities working
collaboratively we believe that we would
want more reassurances as to what is in
it for northeast derbyshire and the
people and communities within it
we are of course in favor of extra
funding and evolved powers for northeast
establishment after all we have as a
local government in general has suffered
a decade of puts to the tory austerity
policies but not at any price and above
all
not at the detriment of people living
northeast harvesting
hopefully you've heard of our comments
and reservations which you can feed into
the process and i accept what you've
said and i understand there'll be
another chance to vote on this further
down the line and that is when we can
make our final decision but at this
point
we feel as though we just need to stay
at this point keep the options open
so
that's where we sit now
your comments or questions council
shipment
thank you chair um i agree with almost
everything uh council mark has just said
apart from his last bit because sound
will be voted against this
um
i agree with the fact that
we want to work collaboratively with us
that's major services where it can
emerge
but
what we're in the press is we end up
with an electric mirror
and if we end up with an elected mayor
it's another layer of government in
between that people have no relation to
whatsoever
this talk of tax risers so an additional
tax
revenue that's going to be coming in to
pay for their expensive officers and
staff that's unnecessary there's nothing
right now
stopping the government if if there was
the political will invested in local
governments in derbyshire absolutely
nothing it's just that there's no
political will at the highest levels of
this country which is why we're not
getting that money we don't have to go
down an elected mayor there's other ways
we can do it we've been we've been
working with for how many years now and
we're pulling away from that the way
things currently are so we have been
saving money we're actually coming away
from that and blowing more money on on
you know taking services and what i
think it's just totally wrong and what's
the point in now spending more money and
sending officers to join these meetings
when ultimately we're going to end up
with more bureaucracy and higher taxes
for people in north east africa i could
not vote for this and i won't be able to
stay in at all i think i feel that
strongly about it i need to go against
it
hancock
thank you chair
again i'm echovocals the shipment
council marcus said
we know ourselves we had a conversation
about anyone to go up in collections we
know how different were the
establishments
so this whole idea about
making things on a bigger scale we've
seen himself before time and time again
so there are areas
[Music]
when it comes to services it needs to be
kept as local as possible and uh to me
that this whole thing is actually taking
away
local democracy it's not actually
helping build towards it so again we
knew that
losses may be quite good lived with the
voting against it
obviously we keep it open minded
[Music]
um quite a lot to try and address there
obviously fully respect the position of
the opposition and and
you know decide however you want but
to try and go through some of the issues
that were raised
i think in terms of the conflict um
i mean
barry about this as he was able to speak
but i have not taken part in any of the
negotiations on the county perspective
this is not my role to do so i don't
attend vision derbyshire meetings as a
as a county counselor i attend them as
legal with district council and that is
my position throughout so i don't
believe that that conflict exists i'm
here to represent nothing starting i
always attend those meetings very
clearly with northeast africa's position
we don't always agree with what's on the
table within the partnership
outside the tent at the moment because i
think that's the best place to be so i
don't think that that conflict exists at
the same
the same
level
the question of what do we get out of it
well it's still a bit unclear because
we're only at the very beginning of
negotiation but it could be you know
hundreds of millions of pounds uh for
the whole region um the the east
midlands as an area
has massively suffered with under
investment but that's not just uh tory
government under investment that's
that's history that goes over the past
20 25 years that's that's across
government and
if you want to if you want to look at
the facts and the the data around this
this is not a political issue this is a
historic issue with the east veterans
and this is our opportunity potentially
to turn that around and i think it would
be foolish of us to turn away from uh
all of this all of what's happening on
the basis that we don't like it we don't
want it to happen the reality is as a
district we don't have any veto in this
anyway so we might as well try and be at
the table and try and get what we can
for northeast so that's the really
important thing from my perspective and
i really can't stress enough this is a
negotiation we don't know what the final
deal would
um
you know it's better that we're at least
participating there at the table ready
to engage you know ready to discuss and
ready to champion northeast that's
that's the role that i think
um just on the point with one final
point around tax rises um a lot to be
made of that in the media but i think
it's it's a bit of a storm in a teacup
to be honest the reality is that um yes
i believe the county has put forward
that they would like the ability to
add a precept of all of the directly
elected mayors around the
uh around the country i think there's 10
in total
for that the powers to do that and of
the ten only two have actually used them
and it you know it might not surprise
members to be aware that the two members
that have used the labour members
um so eight eight for the election
have those powers but do not choose to
use them so the idea that it's always
about taxing or creating additional
bureaucracy is not necessarily the case
i think really this is about seeing what
we can get it might be that a direct
elected mayor is not a price that we
want to pay for the deal that's on the
table but i don't know that yet so why
don't we just participate continue to be
involved and find out and then come back
again
we're not really voting on anything
other than uh in this paper wanting to
just continue to be involved be engaged
keep you all informed of what's
happening and then go from there
thank you so we've had the
recommendations moved and seconded all
those in favor
all those against
the abstentions
the recommendations are carried
[Music]
um so this paper is to agree to
collaborate with um other derbyshire
council councils the districts uh
borough and county
and in fact it actually comes out of the
districts coming together with counties
the portfolio holders
from each district and area
uh to discuss exactly what we can
collaborate on so it's sort of the best
of vision development really and what
it's all about
rather than the bigger that
unitarization
and so as it stands county have got
their climate strategy and we've got as
a district we've got our final strategy
and there's clearly a set of things that
sort of fit in between that we should
really benefit from working on together
and so far we've identified
five themes which are listed in section
2.4 of the report in detail
later in chapter 5.
and that includes things like
procurement planning charging
infrastructure business emissions energy
generation green innovation green jobs
improving housing efficiency
working with our community to help
reduce their carbon footprint travel
reducing waste increasingly
all those sorts of things where
working together would be uh more
effective than working alone
and depending on what the theme is
different councils might take the lead
there's nothing prescriptive about it
uh that there's certainly no point in us
or reinventing the wheel
so this strategy is a starting point it
will continue to evolve and new things
will probably be added into it other
things we might decide to
roll our own on as it goes i think we
have a great starting point for working
together
so i'll move the recommendation in the
paper to endorse the publication and
delivery of the vegan culture climate
change strategy
for the secondary council
commenting questions please council
market
just a comment really and
[Music]
it's a good document it's a good
strategy and it does show the advantages
of
working together across the county and i
don't think we can do this on his own
thanks for doing uh
but i i i welcome the paper and
jeremy and uh well then
that's the shipment
thank you chair um
agreement knows all again um this is the
source of the vision dancers should be
used for that short collaborative
working like this we don't need to have
this extra layer of your opposite we
should be doing it on projects like this
across the county um so we can actually
work together but like i said what we
need is money from government
the government could be giving us money
for projects like this and strategies
like this instead they're trying to lure
us in um into other structures where we
have no veto to get eye on
another comment
thank you thank you thank you sorry
thank you chair um just to just to add i
think
whilst we're talking about collaborative
we're one of the key key districts that
actually borders with with another
county
so um we can't pretend that the top end
of our country is important in south
yorkshire so it would be nice to
actually see some engagement there and
it actually extends beyond
[Music]
good lord
[Music]
i just i thought i'd just found out some
of the contradictions there between the
previous paper in this paper i mean
cancer shipment refers to this being
exactly the sort of thing that the
garbage or is should be doing well this
is the sort of thing that these
endowment is doing and that's the whole
point i think there was another and then
and then there was a request for more
investment in the in the in the district
and more investment
well that's what's gonna happen through
the county deal and through you know
what's been put forward there so when we
when we try to start a negotiation with
an account stats trying to start a
negotiation and council shipment says he
doesn't want it and then moreover we've
got councillor hancock then suggesting
we ought to expand this super authority
to kill the south yorkshire as well
which is just absolutely beyond me
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chair um
[Music]
yes i mean vision derbyshire is an
example let's make this an example of
what we can do with our current
structures essentially you know we've
got um what we've got eight districts or
seven districts or whatever city
and let's work together and i agree on
the sheffield point as well that's
working
we have done a little bit we went to see
a factory doing um modular housing which
was also low carbon housing and that was
raised by sheffield city region but
there is more we've done there
absolutely
um
and uh in terms of collaborating that's
also not forget our parishes
um
50 odd parishes is a huge number
and they have influence so it's all
about collaborating and i think we're in
a good place to um
to
progress that it's all levels thank you
thank you for telling councils who
weren't on council when we debated city
russia
[Music]
thank you so we're fighting 12 the
original homes limited
limited presentations
just did a pause between written homes
and limited
so i'm going to
invite
you know please and your colleagues
speak with us the floor is yours
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we've been asked this afternoon to
provide some information about the
work and investment that's going on in
the district council's housing stock and
i'm not going to read every point in the
presentation or understand what happened
but
issues
so there is a commitment in the district
to
regenerate undertake works to the
council's heart to treat homes
um in 2019
uh an external expert curtains were
instructed to review the council's
non-traditional housing stock and
identified priorities for investment
over the next five years
the council working with written homes
have secured 2.1 million pounds worth of
government funding to the green homes
project to support energy improvements
to council-owned housing stock this is
for the provision of external award
insulation
this has enabled an acceleration in the
program for improving counseling and
housing
the council has invested a further 10.4
million pounds in addition to the
central equivalent funding and we are
currently delivering a total investment
of 12.5 million pounds
that investment has allowed work to be
undertaken to 427
the council non-traditional housing
stock
these were
identified as priorities from the
guernse report
and the work to improve the insulation
levels those homes will be complete by
june 22 in line with the government's
study requirements
works have been undertaken in meekley
dronfield bunsen
westington barlow woolly war holly moore
side running shop and
so right across the district where there
is need for improving the quality of
housing
there are around 900 council owned homes
that still require investment at the end
of this program and we are currently
working very hard with colleagues at the
council on prioritizing where we will be
moving to next and the level of
investment would be required to continue
the straightforward work
as you will probably be aware and the
non-traditional housing stocks
are located right across the district in
all communities and we have a number of
different types
of properties
the common theme amongst these
properties is they are hard to heat
and that can
produce the risk of fuel poverty for
residents living in those
and they can present a very high
maintenance burden as well
the improvements that we are currently
delivering and have plans in the future
benefit the families living in these
homes because they make them
much warmer and easier to keep warm they
improve the aesthetics of individual
properties and the streets in the
communities in which they are located
and they tie in the council's commitment
to reduce carbon emissions across the
district
in addition to external wall
installation and we also need to take
detailed works and new windows roofware
required and quite some quite
technically challenging structural works
for some of the properties
and this allows us to deliver a whole
house
so that we tackle all the issues with
that particular property in one go
there's some photos in the presentation
of typical properties before and after
the works and hopefully you can
see the improvement that this investment
has led to
one of the key issues for residents
whilst living in these homes is that
there is a level of disruption during
the works depending on the property time
and the disruption is mainly external
and fairly minimal for some of the more
challenging property types the
disruption is significant and
we are working on
are particularly challenging and within
the presentation there are some images
of the type of disruption that residents
have to
be supported with to enable us to
achieve the level of work that is
required
the area properties in particular
require a full removal of the external
wall
of the existing property uh full
structural works um to transfer the load
from the existing steel columns within
the buildings to a new external wall and
that requires temporary property to be
inserted into the properties whilst
families are occupied
and so very intrusive and it's very
important that we support customers
during that process
before we start working on any property
we want to take a full survey of each
individual property to establish
the
individual requirements for that
particular home and we work with the
customer
within that home their family their
support network and anybody that needs
to be involved to help that family those
people in their homes to cope with the
level of disruption
we go through for the induction program
with customers where we explain to them
in great detail how the words will be
undertaken the programme of works
the disruption
the key points of contact both from
the
council and from national contractor so
they know where to turn to their
experience and difficulties and we get
to know those individuals families so
that we can make sure that we clear our
support to suit them some families are
one person maybe two people in the
property we also have homes we've got
large numbers of residents in there and
support these are different for each
type of home
we provide detailed information to each
family about what will be happening when
things will be happening and how to get
support if they are struggling
we also make families aware that
weather conditions can affect the
program that works and some of the work
that we do uh cannot be undertaken in
cold weather
[Music]
very wet weather and we have to
make them aware that they may sometimes
be delayed
and that's not because we're trying to
be difficult but that's because we need
to make sure we deliver a technically
compliant project at the end of the day
we provide constant support through the
contractors resident liaison officer and
the site management in each location
our own path of works
make sure that the technical
specifications are met and we provide
dedicated customer layers and officers
for each and every home should they need
support and we visit them regularly to
make sure that the works are going to
program and that any problems that arise
are being dealt with on a regular basis
where customers do raise concerns we
address those we've had raised concerns
raised through some of
satisfaction
we regularly inspect the site works as
you would expect and we make sure that
at the end of the project both the
government's criteria for funding
and our specifications and the
expectations of this council
we complete the handover process by
making sure that customers
feedback and experience
is taken account and we use that
information to improve what we do and
learn from the from issues that have
risen during the project
and we will also make always ensure that
where a problem has been raised we will
address that concern and look to
learn from that experience
the second presentation is just a little
bit of information about what currently
is going on in terms of regeneration
projects as we speak today
um i touched on earlier about
curtin was being appointed 210
detailed surveys of the council housing
stock this is the second survey they've
actually done they did one back in 2008
and to actually start the process of
looking at regeneration across the
industry
and there's a little bit of detail about
the different types of properties there
are in the uh distribution council own
i'm not going to go into any details
about those
but what i can say is that all the
collision recommendations from the 2009
report were fully addressed in the time
frames that government said
we're now delivering the next set of
priorities to 427 pounds of taxes talked
about
and
by the end of the current financial year
that's 22-23 then the priority one
repairs to the area properties will also
be complete
the remaining works of the councils
owned non-trad homes
will be programmed in over the next few
years and the recommendations from
kunsan are included in the um capital
program financially and working with
january
in addition to doing work to the
council's non-traditional
existing staff
we're also delivering the projects for
the council at pioneer james mark where
we are constructing nine bullets
this is a scheme where the council
as well as providing the funding to
build the homes
and they have invested an additional
amount of 18 000 pounds per property to
install new technology in these homes
they will have solar panels on the roofs
they will have air source heat pumps
on the floor using
assistive technology for residents to
help them be able to stay in their own
home for as long as possible electric
vehicle charging points and dedicated
parking provision for every new home on
united states
at the same time we are also
constructing new parking provision for
every existing home within that
community
in addition to the time view project
we currently have a planning application
being considered for the development of
sensitive new
homes of whiteheads avenue in north
wingfield
and for those members that have been
around for a little while i'll remember
that this is a follow-on from other work
over a number of years to both improve
the quality and provision of housing in
springfield and deal with a large area
of non-traditional housing
and we are looking forward to having an
outcome of the planning application
hopefully next month and we are
currently in the process of
working to procure specialist teams and
a developer to
get onto site later this year and we
hope to be starting to build new homes
later this year with some of the
completions during next year
and so we've got a two year
that project
we're also working council officers and
colleagues on looking at
what new properties are available
through the section 106 process
where affordable homes are required to
be delivered on other new build sites
and we're doing uh phrasing the number
of schemes at the moment working with
colleagues online with the council
and we're also looking at where there
are further opportunities in the
district around council and gary sites
and other areas where the council may be
able to bring forward more new homes
further regeneration opportunities in a
range of locations across industry
thank you any questions for mr clark
[Music]
[Music]
we've got a lot of single people
in the 60s and 70s
married
[Music]
they've been on the list of two or three
years you can't get the one goal from
the money
and that's building up building up
are you thinking
well
obviously if you're selling council
houses
[Music]
each
however there are a number of properties
that are also required here as well and
i can certainly provide the facts
if that's acceptable
and in terms of
um there is currently a review of the
council's uh allocations policy underway
uh and that's the issue that you've
raised is one that
has been raised elsewhere as well and
the process for reviewing
[Music]
or individuals that want to move to
smaller accommodation we do everything
we can to try and support those and but
the real large demand for housing
is aware
and
a lot of people say that one of those
for an awful long time
[Music]
there's a mixture
wherever possible
moves to accommodation
2023
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
with me
traditional way where we started it it
looked massive it still is but without
you i think in particular we won't be
where we are trying to tackle these
non-traditional albums so on behalf of
[Music]
thank you chair um just to echo i mean
the work that's been done here is
it's long great
um i mean the thing that brings to my
mind here is some disruption when i was
a child
and we were moved out when there was
this level of work so
i mean obviously there are support
mechanisms for
it is really just an assurance that
our residents are going to get
the support they need to because
[Music]
the last point first if i may share and
i can assure you and all members that we
have a really strong customer support
team and they really are very
experienced in doing that we've been on
this journey for 89 years now and
they really are there to support
customers they
if they need the technical team to stop
work they are empowered to do that to
make sure the christians are supported
and it's incredible to them that you
know we get lots of positive praises
some on the back of one of the
presentations that we do
[Music]
this is not about me and this is about
homes
and led
[Music]
but it's a team effort it's working
directly with the council this is not
all about this is about the joint
working that we've been doing
thank you very much it is appreciated
don't forget the brilliant board as well
[Music]
um we managed sure the houses are
absolutely amazing
and i know that people are really happy
about it my only one thing is that um is
you talk about doing
the work that you've done but lots of
insulation is very important as well and
i haven't heard any mention of that
because it's all right you know keeping
the houses warm but heat rises as you
know and it's like keeping the walls and
the floors warm but they need to you
know
so
is that do we talk to them about loft
insulation do we help them with
purchasing of insulation is it even very
very expensive
so for council home owned homes um
there's been a number of programs over
the last 10 years and that focused on
topping with lost insulation because it
was a low hanging fruit it was an easy
win and so every council owned home in
the district has a good level of loss
insulation when a home becomes void it
is
[Music]
three or four years will have um
[Music]
so in terms of private home owners
we always contact
every private homeowner in this state
where we are currently delivering um a
project on behalf of this council
and we offer them the opportunity of
working with our appointed contractors
to have the work done at the same time
now they have to engage independently
with our contractors and they have to
pay for the work themselves but we do
help facilitate that in terms of contact
and need to talk to exception
and the green homes project didn't
include an element of funding for
homeowners
[Music]
um but there are a number of schemes of
being considered nationally about ways
of helping individual homeowners to
access this type of investment
council's uh
environmental health team also have an
officer that provides
individual support and advice on energy
conservation and signposting to
other agencies that may be up to help
homeowners
[Music]
[Music]
the numbers are fairly low to be fair
but there are examples whereas
the opportunity
yeah
i also like to
say thank you also
supporting these investments
there's no doubt that residents are
thrilled with the uh outcome i think
this is why it's important to show you
the before and afters
yes they recognize as a challenge with
12 weeks of
builders in their property but they
all
say
not just the aesthetics but it's the
actual energy saving and also in terms
of the environment
so a big big thanks to everybody
involved and
we are really proud that
levine
very informative presentation or two
presentations and they're giving the
council additional insight into the
very positive work original home so
thank you for coming along today and
updating us thank you to both of you
so item 13 to answer any questions from
members asking the procedure 9.2
that we have received one question so
council barry the floor is yours
[Music]
thank you chair um
it's quite a simple question really it
was following on from the initial
announcement about
climate change and everything we
discussed electric charging points in
northeast derbyshire
can the portfolio provide the following
details such as the delivery meaningful
implementation monitoring and scientific
research challenges
and i know that the portfolio did get in
touch with me but i was on holiday
thank you very much
thank you
thank you council barry and as for the
three parts to this there's our own land
there's our council housing and there's
the wider northeast derbyshire
so on our own land first
at our leisure centers we've installed
challenging points
but we will also be installing charging
points by the shelby park development
and we've surveyed our other main car
parks for suitability and we have
applied for grants for some of them
and those grants are based uh assessed
by the providers based on the demand
and uh so far some of them might make
the cuts but we've
[Music]
and
then on our uh council housing has
just been discussing how important that
is um
large numbers of people there
so uh new council housing and pioneers
we've heard we'll have new charging
points and a good thing to put that on
four new council houses require them
an obvious one to consider there
and and as neil mentioned as well
whenever this has been avoided as well
with deep insulation
it's a prime time to consider putting
charging points and so we're we're
investigating whether that's an option
[Music]
the main responsibility for charging
infrastructure lies with the county
council and they are
taking the lead on this
and we're working with them by the
division of china strategy for example
and i believe the county will release
their charging point strategy in the
next few months
and then finally there's also some key
national decisions that have
[Music]
been made late last year such as um
requiring all new housing to have car
charging points that hopefully will be
finalized later this year
right to ask a supplementary question
i think actually he's answered most
foods i mean i'm an electric car user
myself and i find it difficult
come on
um i mean there have been various
government schemes over the years i'm
not quite sure if there's one running
exactly today to give grants to support
people doing installations at home
um
it's uh
it's sort of not really just a council
remit to provide grants to that though
it would be very expensive for us to be
doing that
so
we want to focus more on particular
areas and a big big example of course is
our council housing where i think we
will do the most benefit for people who
are
um
[Music]
[Music]
have been submitted the first is
from councillor shipman so over to you
thank you chair um it's almost the same
promotion that we had six months ago
except there's the additional bit where
since we last had a discussion in this
council chamber there's been more
information that's come to light on this
issue
when county carried out the assessment
that residents are asking for or at
least part of the assessment
all along
um
but
the whole point of this motion is to
just get it back to planning because
like i was saying earlier there's no
way in this constitution for it to get
back to planning other than this chamber
agreed to send it
um so i think we need to make that
decision so that the planning committee
can look at all the evidence available
and come up with an informed decision
because right now pete i think everyone
knows bits and bobs about it
there's not been that debate
where all the evidence could be looked
at
and then that decision could be formed
and i'm sure that because i've been
attending planning committee when this
has been debated
there's a frustration across all parties
on that planet
because
on one end there's all these issues
being raised but on the other hand
council officers are saying to members
that they can't make a decision because
at that point
where they are in the planning process
those things can't be considered
so it's a bit like well we can't look at
it in the planning committee
so the only way for it for it to be
is if it was sent back from this chamber
so that the
issue around revocation could be debated
and all that evidence comes alive and
then obviously the
decisions
but that's not happened yet and that's
what they could do
[Music]
i just want to make the point that play
cross british council have been behind
these residents from day one we objected
to the original application you know
obviously
and i went to the original
planning meeting and spoke up for the
residents there so we will be supporting
this motion and voting with it so i hope
we can get some movement thank you
[Music]
[Music]
when we discussed this last i fully
appreciate the concerns of like
residents particularly those in and
around windermere range we've suffered
from from the threat of flooding living
in a swedish area and have really
distracted me sort of putting issues in
the past
whilst we your new planning applications
can't solve those historical issues in
this area
the science allocation
or the science allocation i understand
the concerns and we've continued to try
and find a way forward with this
since we've activated it in this chamber
we've hadn't been part of lots of
meetings and conversations and i know
transformation has to
try and find a solution to these
concerns as part of the issues during
the recent amendment to a section 73
application
um and discussions on flooding concerns
related to this we did manage to get an
amendment or addition in the form of the
developer installing an additional water
storage tank at their own cost which
will provide extra capacity in this area
and on site during these heavy rainfall
or by water levels
in addition to that following other
repetitions
correspondence with some surrounding
residents understand
[Music]
as a district council we don't have any
duties or responsibilities in relation
to flooding matters other than the
statutory comments and advice
for the authority and to take those on
board as the motion says who are the
experts and responsible parties
however given the historic experiences
in this area and the proximity of
existing and new values
and those residents concerns remain and
i
could understand clarity for residents
in this regard
so i think we should use this debate on
this motion to add our voice and
position as a council to support
residents and pushing for that survey to
be done as well
so i'm proposing an amended motion which
i've submitted to um
[Music]
but the amendments are two-part first
thing in relation to bullet points or
points tonight i'm proposing a few
amendments to avoid any legal issues or
accusations and to focus on the key
choosing facts and secondly i'm
proposing to amend the resolution to
urge external parties to find a way to
carry out a survey or hydraulic modeling
which would then give planning policy
something to review in relation to the
site and referring the planning and
referring the matters then without that
data in place wouldn't give them
any new evidence or details and what's a
quite technical matter to base their
discussion
so i think that as cancer shipments
mentioned the model or survey is
ultimately a part of the matter in this
that we determine it for residents and
committee
so i hope this is a good opportunity to
unite as a chamber council and pass this
amended motions
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so i'll just uh can we just pause so
that everyone can receive a copy of the
amendment
and unless you're accepting
them
[Music]
hmm
what's up
[Music]
so
papers
right the amended version has been
circulated so we'll debate the amendment
as proposed and second
so now on the
debate about the amended
version
thank you chair um although this
amendment on the surface looks
reasonable the problem you've got is
that word is
because
as you well know in other distinctions
with developer council council anybody
everybody
no one's going to carry out that survey
nobody has agreed to carry out that
survey so basis on the word if that
model isn't completed the planning
committee is never going to see this
this is going to get kicked into one
grass
and nothing will happen
what this needs to say is
to either this council pays for that
survey and then it goes back to
committed to planning committee
or stick with the original motion
you can't have this where we're relying
on this survey which council cupid knows
full well it's never going to be carried
out because any of these an eddc and
county are saying the developer needs to
do it the developer is saying we don't
need to do it
and therefore the amended motion
is is it will kill off this old idea
because it's never going to happen
and i could not support this at this
amendment because that's the intention
of it and i'm sure counselors duplicate
knows full well that's the intention
and i just think it's ridiculous
comments
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
shipment but if needs taken it needs to
be when that modeling is completed
um and i i would
in terms of remember to take out that
whole first sentence because the model
needs some confusion
[Music]
yeah i think i liked all that when i
first looked i thought yeah that's not
wrong with that but having just listened
to work to the argument i tend to agree
uh what's been said that uh
i think we should we just think we can
bonk on this obviously and we'll vote
against the amendment
[Music]
any other
comments on the
[Music]
and that wasn't the intention the whole
point of this as i've just outlined in
my speech is to urge external parties to
carry out a survey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
completed
that's
the writer reply
exercise so we move to the vote all
those in favor of the amendment show
your hands
all those against
and the abstentions
when the amendment is carried
now becomes the substantive
motion before council
so any
comments questions on the now
substantive motion
if not so we're going to vote on the
substantive motion all those
council shipments
i am a bit disappointed actually the
we're going downstream because as i just
said
this is if we don't get that
um like i just said the
the fact that we're relying on that
relying on a survey to be completed by
governor of anybody
where there's no funding available
is going to hold it up
like if that report never comes this is
never going to end up in front of the
planet
we've already got some we've already got
that part of the survey well something
countered
on the levels in the brawl
which planning could quite easily look
at and make a decision based on that
and i think that if this went back to
planet then at least
the council's in a position in a
stronger position than it is currently
which is it's got no leg to stand on it
can't force a developer to do anything
it can't make pcc do anything
um and i do fear that we are now just
going to kick this into the long grass
and nothing's going to move forward
because that model don't come
nothing will happen
so reluctantly i will vote for it's
better than nothing
but still
it's not going to achieve i'll honestly
i will
i'll bet 100 quid that this does not end
up in planet i'll donate to taftgate
hospice
if you don't
exercise so we'll move to the note on
the now substantive motion all those in
favor
and one against
the extensions
[Music]
motion is carried
[Music]
uh i know some will think it's not the
role of district councillors to get
involved in national issues
but i'm afraid it is the only avenue
that we as politicians with a victory
get our chance to voice our concerns on
things like this
only today
if you read it the local government
information unit
one of the articles was out of the daily
express
no less stated that food banks are
facing an impossible situation they are
struggling to support more and more
people
unable to afford food
whilst their capacity is reduced due to
lack of donations and volunteers
it's bad enough that we need food banks
but when they can't talk something needs
to be done
this [ __ ] is not asking for a lot
just for us as an authority to try a
[ __ ] as a council and asking our mps
to ask the government to try a bit
harder as well so hopefully you'll just
you will support this thank you
that's the reader
i'm going to set an emotion
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
very
unfair it is also worth mentioning that
even
parliament
actually
somehow
this council reduced the funding from 20
that was at 22 000
to 10 000
and then they put it all together
this is for
so all the outreach
used to do no longer
last year
they brought into this district
1
from 48
098 pounds worth of support to our
constituents
but this council
can't fund them
i think this council should reinstate
this funding to help those most
vulnerable
[Music]
thank you chair um i i think this is
this is a good function this one i
support
at paris levels um
[Music]
it doesn't take a huge amount of
parishes
so i actually agree with what council
has said that there is the potential to
vote for the council to do more this
isn't actually putting a huge a huge
result on the district council i think
that the least
is for this and uh
thank you chair uh as we've said from
cancer also
the javascript
workers association i thought they had
reduced by 20 grand
and we've just seen the conservative
group vote to raise the special
allowances and salaries by 23.
so clearly the issue isn't money
and i think that this is a good motion
it's something i will support um
and i think we just we should be looking
at ways to
have all these different groups
delivering service for services for us
and not to cutting them they are
ultimately getting people back into work
they're supporting people when they're
at the most vulnerable they're stopping
people going into debt which ultimately
that that cost is passed on towards if
it's not dealt with early
and i think that it's not this emotion
it's not asking too much
[Music]
i don't think anyone could argue about
the significant financial pressures
facing our residents at the moment that
that point clearly isn't in question
but there are some issues with the
proposed resolutions in this in this
motion on the issue of fees and charges
the first bullet point um the motion
makes no attempt to explain which fees
and charges in particular you would want
us to review or
revise
um and i would ask that someone doesn't
have to make that clear we have done a
desktop exercise and reviewed them in
preparation for the motion and i think
the following points i'd like to make
are that some are statutory anyway
anyway so they're set by nationals
a classic example would be planning fees
and many of the discretionary fees and
charges that we have in place already
have assistance packages built into them
um for example pest control has a 50
discount
for anyone on certain income related
benefits
we have leisure discounts and
concessions for
service users including those who
receive
pensions and benefits
and generally fees and charges are set
to enable cost recovery
for example with environmental health or
to contribute to our costs in the case
of leisure and to reduce these is only
going to
impact on the county's own budget and i
distinctly
simply recall only a couple of months
ago opposition council was expressing
concern over the levels of savings still
to achieve when we set the budget and
yet these same councils are now calling
for further pressures to be based on the
budget which could impact on frontline
services
and moreover what the motion fails to
recognize is that we too as an
organization are facing similar cost
pressures as our residents
the latest forecasted impact on our
budget from the increase in energy and
fuel costs
is 660 000 pounds a year
on the issue of welfare advice and debt
management we continue to support the
voluntary and community sector
organizations who provide this support
like cab or the
law centre to the tune of 130 000 pounds
per year that's been the case for the
past
many years i don't know exactly how long
but several years so the overall
allocation of uh funding that goes to
the community voluntary sector hasn't
changed uh council hearthstone is
absolutely right to point out we have
made changes in terms of the way
which organizations we
[Music]
unemployed workers centre uh no longer
received funding um citizens advice
bureau received an extra ten thousand
pounds at the time
citizens advice many a time i've been
doing fantastic work uh they do a lot of
uh duplicated work without the laws
garbage unemployed workers center and
importantly they do it on a neighborhood
basis which is really important
and these groups over the over the whole
have supported 19 000 residents so we're
at 19 000 households last year
um we work with loads of different
partner organizations like the healthy
norfolk establishment partnership its
financial inclusion group
to provide free advice to those who need
it our housing delivery partners
richmond homes have a dedicated team who
can offer advice and support about money
management and welfare benefits
to all of our council home tenants and
our own housing options team continue to
work with those who become were at risk
of homeless
with their referral service
we have prevention through things like
the deposit guarantee scheme
and we are close them to the darwin law
centre and outreach services for our
sleepers
and following on from the government
grant through the household support fund
we helped to prevent 75 people becoming
homeless
over the winter and there's lots of
other ways that we were supporting
residents things like what we've just
heard from wriglet around the ewi scheme
that's helping to save an average of 186
pounds per household per year for those
tenants who are who have the works done
obviously throughout the pandemic we all
know the council pulled out all the
stops to support residents everyone
could our finance team distributed
grants token 45 million pounds
to struggling businesses across the
district we continue to deliver their
regular jobs fairs to help local people
find local jobs
we also support our own community
employment advisors and we do what
cancer hancock said um we provide that
direct uh support for people to find
work uh with frozen leisure membership
fees for two years
there's a huge amount that we already do
to support residents and clearly you
know anyone can make the argument that
there's more that can be done and
obviously we'll always continue to keep
that under review
and assess wherever we can be more we
will be more we very much aim to support
our residents but i can't escape the
conclusion despite what um council
barking says this is a politically
charged uh notion i do think there is an
intention there and therefore we'll be
voting against it having said all of
what i've said and we will continue to
do what we tend to support our residents
[Music]
[Music]
my only concern is that um you say you
know you can't amount this 200 or
written or 268 pound per year saving on
eating that is how much people are now
having to pay per month
for all their gas
and we've got people that are working
that on a low income um
and that i think we can do more my
biggest concern is about people that are
not going to be able to pay their rent
they're not going to be able to pay the
council tax so we're going to have more
evictions coming along
and so we're going to have rent poverty
we're going to have council tax poverty
we're going to have food poverty so i
think these are things that we need to
really sit down as a council and look at
i mean i know of somebody that you know
that
they were paying 70 pound a month
for their gas and electricity they've
now been told they've got to pay 300
pounds and this is somebody on the that
works but is on a minimum wage how are
they supposed to do that with two young
children do you know what i mean
i disagree we can do a lot more on my
biggest concern as i say is rent in
council tax poverty and also people
being evicted and it's not just council
house people that are going to be
evicted it's going to be people that are
working nurses
carers and all that that are on a low
income and can't afford to pay the
council tax and can't afford to pay the
food and i think we need to look at it a
lot more as this council
[Music]
we never talk about those low paid
workers that own their own homes or
after private rent you know what do we
do to help those people because this is
hitting them
as much as it is
hitting people in council properties and
we seem to forget those people
you know i have daughters that work in
the nhs they are not paid a fortune they
work in the community my youngest
daughter's electric bill has just gone
on phenomenal it's gone all right i
think it's children to quit a month
she doesn't earn enough to be paying
that so i do think we need it's not just
looking at what's happening with the
council tenants which are you know
important to us all but so are those
low-paid workers are in their own homes
working hard to keep a roof over their
own house
[Music]
[Music]
but i can't help feeling like our
leaders always said that it was a very
political notion we've mixed up here b
and c
when you look at a i'd like to reiterate
the request from the leader about the
the charges the review of charges and
fees which we do anyways
and i'd like to ask which charge from
which fees and the only ones i could see
were the pest control
discounts on benefits
the leisure pass and the conception
passed our leisure services
so i'd like to know
uh and a little uh
i think cancer readable coming
afterwards i'd like to know which
challenges you actually mean
because we do give
some discounts already
when it comes to be i'm very supportive
of systems advice uh
absolutely i think we do fantastic work
and if it comes to pass next year that
there is i'll set an account
but if it does come to say that there is
an increased
promise next year i would support that
excellent work i really do
um certainly not to see
without the shout out he's a shame
that's him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's fine
i'm actually trustee with citizen's
advice so i can talk with some
confidence about that we are
appreciative of the grants that have
come from the northeast
we used to get 75 000. we now get 85
000.
the extra 10 000
we are going to use to try and recruit
more volunteers
to help deliver the service for people
who don't know
susan's advice is 50
staff to 50 volunteers
so we're going to use that money to try
and get more volunteers to come and help
us
and 10k is two days
a week of somebody
[Music]
going into a catalogue of how you're
going to spend the money so i'm going to
stop i'm going to stop you there okay i
didn't realize that
you got a lot in them
anything else
come out to your council reader to
exercise your right to reply
thank you chad
you can't support it i um think emotion
is asking for too much really
in terms of
this
and it says fees it i just i think means
generally all the fees that the council
exercises on our residents can it be
reviewed and looked at and can we
support as much as possible
the cabinet are in the position to be
able to do that
so generally
all our fees that affect all of our
residents can we do as much as we
possibly can to support them
i absolutely agree with uh council barry
this is extending not just to council
residents it's all residents across all
of our districts that are facing really
hard and tough times
we've got to remember that there are
real people at the end of everything
that they do and i was
wanting to be a counsellor to support
those people so that this motion has
been brought with that in mind that we
want to try and support our residents
that are coming to us
calling us every day
with their struggles
and i don't believe that this does any
harm in showing that we do support them
in terms of
point c
i absolutely want that to stay in as
councillor walker said we're not
national politicians in this room but
there are councillors in this room that
have
positions where they can influence those
people more than others
that are in government and can go and
lobby and make those decisions so i
absolutely want that point to stay in
this motion
we all know across north east africa
there are families that are really
struggling and we all know that children
born into families with poverty will
experience worse outcomes
if they're living in a household that is
struggling with poverty
and we'll go round and round again
so this function isn't asking for too
much it's just asking for every bit that
we can do
to try and make life a little bit easier
for those people in northeast culture so
i absolutely struggle with this motion
thank you chad
shabbat
this is the only chance we get
as local
politicians whether we like the term or
not that's what we are
and this is the chance that we get to
represent these concerns at a meeting
like this so yeah it is political
and i know we now grow
everybody in our group meeting we're
concerned about this because they know
people that it's effective and this this
is why we brought them
and like tracy says uh
counselor reader that there are people
in this room that have got
that know people personally that can try
and go back to government and express
those concerns that's what we do in this
room
we're trying to go across the concerns
that we've got that you can then feed
back to the people who can make a
difference i accept we do a lot of
northeast startership
there's a lot of good way because uh you
know all the help we give people either
through written or through other things
but don't mean we can't have another
look at some of the things whether we
take away the the
the refused election you know picking up
stuff
and
for a couple years we don't charge for
that or for the to the best people we
could take that away and i know it
impacts on something else because if
that that's always the case
but that's where we are and it is
we are at a bad stage at the moment
people are not feeling it yet fully
because the gas and electric bills have
knocked out dropping not letting go
don't let it go so
this is this is it's going to be really
really bad
and that's what we're asking for and the
most important bit to this is c
and so we can actually influence central
government to do more we can do what we
can and it's only on the fringes what
can happen is if government can start
reducing people's bills and tackling the
energy companies and all that sort of
stuff we can do that central government
can do that
and that's what we're asking for in that
to see so and again this is the issue
around that thousand workers and this
politics in that i accept that but they
do do a good job as does the sit-ins
advice of the law center but i've made
my point it's there in front of you we
know what the result's going to be but i
think you should reconsider that and
another have a good thing and vote in
favor of that thank you
so we come now to the vote so all those
in favor of the motion please show your
hands
all those against
[Music]
there are no urgent business items from
myself so can i thank you for your
attendance and prepare the meeting
clones
[Music]
you